va a cumplir dos años y la delgadez de
sus brazos revela un preocupante estado
de salud en el amario digamos que están
en
riesgo en Guatemala es el país con la
tasa de desnutrición Crónica infantil
más alta de latinoamérica según acción
contra el hambre y aquí en el
departamento de Huehuetenango es donde
se encuentra la mayor cantidad de niños
con hambre la inseguridad alimentaria en
esas tierras áridas se agudizó por el
cambio climático dejando desamparadas a
varias familias
ya no hay nada que hacer con él
no sé qué va a ser de mi hijo
siempre ha estado
mucho tristeza por mi bebé para comer
cuando uno se salga con muertes la
desnutrición acarrea otras secuelas con
el estómago vacío los estudiantes no
tienen el desarrollo cognitivo
suficiente para facilitar el aprendizaje
cuando yo hago lectura con ellos apenas
me leen palabras por la falta de
alimentación en sus hogares aquí cuando
empezamos el ciclo escolar pues muchos
niños se inscriben ya tarde por lo mismo
que los padres de familia lo llevan a
trabajar en las fincas para para tener
de qué comer
para salir de esa espiral la fundación
fútbol de Henry le apuesta a la
educación nutricional de las madres
que mejor verdad que de su huerto para
su cocina tener un huerto fecundo y
saber aprovecharlo puede marcar la
diferencia para los niños de la
comunidad vemos verdad familias que los
dos jefes del hogar Este son de
escolaridad muy baja Entonces eso es lo
que les limita a conseguir un buen
trabajo afecta a los niños porque no se
les da la alimentación que ellos
requieren según las Naciones Unidas al
ritmo actual Guatemala necesitaría 100
años para erradicar la desnutrición
Crónica infantil